Darf ich bitte den Schalter drücken?
Selbstverständlich!
Tach zusammen, Jack Pop hier!
Wir sind wieder an der Hochschule in Jena
bei dem Physiker meines Vertrauens Henry.
Hi Jack.
Heute geht es um Magneto, einen X-Men also
einen Mutant und er hat eine besondere Fähigkeit.
Was kann der?
Der kann nämlich Magnetfelder erzeugen.
Und mit diesen Magnetfeldern kann er Dinge
hochheben oder zerquetschen.
Telekinese quasi. Sozusagen.
Der wird in ein Gefängnis aus Plastik gesteckt
damit er nichts anrichten kann und da Henry
ist schon das erste physikalische Problem…
Warum?
Grundsätzlich können Magnetfelder nämlich
alle Materialien irgendwie beeinflussen.
Jedes Material, egal was, wird entweder angezogen
oder abgestoßen.
Auch Kunststoff?
Auch Kunststoff.
Man muss das Magnetfeld nur stark genug machen.
Wir haben euch auch mal ein cooles Video oben
verlinkt, da fliegen nämlich sogar Frösche
und Heuschrecken in einem starken Magnetfeld
und sogar eine Erdbeere wabert da so vor sich hin wenn das Magnetfeld nur stark genug ist.
Wahrscheinlich kriegen wir das mit so einem
Dauermagneten nicht hin, oder?
Das wir so ein starkes Magnetfeld erzeugen?
Dauermagnete erzeugen schwächere Magnetfelder.
Wie man es in der Technik macht, um eben auch Lebewesen irgendwie schweben zu lassen, benutzt man Spulen.
Und wenn da jetzt ein Strom durchfließt,
dann erzeugt dieses Gerät hier ein Magnetfeld.
Und das hat ein dänischer Physiker rausgefunden? Genau.
Hans Christian Ørsted hat experimentell den
Nachweis gebracht, dass eben Ströme auch Magnetfelder erzeugen –
dazu können wir hier einen einfachen
Versuch machen.
Wir haben hier eine Kompassnadel, die eben
ein kleiner Dauermagnet ist, die richtet sich
eben im Magnetfeld der Erde aus und wenn wir
jetzt einen Strom durch den Draht fließen lassen,
dann richtet sich diese Nadel im Magnetfeld
des Drahtes eben aus.
Okay.
Das heißt also, Magneto muss, um diese krassen
Magnetfelder zu erzeugen, einen Strom fließen lassen,
in sich drin quasi? Genau.
Strom sind geladene Teilchen, die sich in
einem Leiter bewegen.
Je mehr geladene Teilchen sich in einem bestimmten
Abschnitt bewegen, desto größer ist die
sogenannte Stromstärke. Die gibt man in Ampere an.
Wenn die sich bewegen gibt es aber ein Problem? Genau.
Wenn die sich bewegen, sind die Atome des
Leiters im Weg.
Das heißt, diese bewegten Elektronen stoßen
die ganze Zeit gegen die Leiteratome und geben
dabei ihre Bewegungsenergie ab.
Die Atome des Leiters nehmen diese Energie
eben auf, fangen dabei selbst an sich zu bewegen und werden dabei heiß.
Das kennen wir vom Zigarettenanzünder im
Auto – da wird auch Strom zu Hitze und man
kann das Zuhause auch ganz einfach nachmachen.
Mit einer Batterie und einem Stück Kaugummipapier.
Wenn man das zwischen die beiden Pole der
Batterie spannt – macht das bitte Zuhause
NICHT ohne Handschuhe, ich mach das hier auf
jeden Fall falsch – das fängt sofort Feuer,
weil hier ein Strom fließt und Hitze entsteht.
In Magneto drin könnte es ganz schnell sehr
heiß werden und um jetzt mal zu gucken wie
heiß müssen wir uns ne konkrete Situation
nehmen.
Ich hab was aus einem X-Men-Film mitgebracht,
da gibt es diese Szene hier in der Magneto
einen ganzen Sattelschlepper anhebt.
Und Henry da gucken wir uns jetzt mal an,
welche Werte wir hier haben, die setzen wir
in ein paar Formeln ein und rechnen mal aus,
welchen Strom Magneto bräuchte um diesen
Sattelschlepper hochheben zu können.
Das machen wir.
Wir machen das über den Energieerhaltungssatz
denn um etwas anzuheben, braucht man Energie.
Magneto muss Energie abgeben, die dann der
Laster aufnimmt.
Die Energie, die der Laster kriegt, ist die
sogenannte Potentielle Energie.
Die ergibt sich aus m mal g mal h.
G und h kennen wir noch aus der Super Mario-Folge.
Wenn Ihr die nicht gesehen habt, die verlinken
wir Euch hier oben. Schaut die Euch auch nochmal an.
Jetzt brauchen wir noch ein Model für Magneto und wir nehmen einfach an, dass Magneto eine Spule ist.
Das können wir nachbauen.
Wir haben nämlich einen süßen Magnetokopf
hier und den kleben wir hier auf die Spule
und dann haben wir tatsächlich eine Magneto-Spule.
Die Energie, die in so einer Spule drin steckt,
die hängt davon ab, welchen Querschnitt die
Spule hat, wie hoch die Spule ist und wie
oft der Draht um den Spulenkern gewickelt ist.
Die Formel, die man dafür braucht um das
zu berechnen ist die Energie der Spule gleich
einhalb mal µ0, µ0 ist die sogenannte Magnetische
Feldkonstante, die gibt an wie gut das Vakuum
Magnetfelder durchlässt, dann geteilt durch
l, die Länge der Spule, dann mal die Querschnittsfläche
mal die Windungszahl und zusätzlich noch
der Strom, der durch die Spule durchfließt.
Was können wir jetzt machen?
Wir wissen, das was aus der Spule rauskommt,
also aus Magneto, muss in den Laster rein.
Das bedeutet, diese beiden Energien sind gleich
– wir können das gleichsetzen – das kennen
die meisten auch noch aus der Schule und jetzt
machen wir noch ein bisschen „Formel-Mambojambo“
und stellen das Ganze nach I0 um…
Wo kriegen wir jetzt die Höhe her?
Die Höhe kriegen wir, genauso wie bei Super
Mario einfach in dem wir uns die Szene angucken
und benutzen Magneto als Messgerät und gucken
wie oft er in die Höhe des Lasters passt.
Die Höhe von Ian McKellen ist genau die Länge
der Spule und wir nehmen einfach an, das die
Wicklungszahl 1.000 ist.
In der Querschnittsfläche steck drin welchen
Radius die Spule hat und wir nehmen einfach
an, dass ist die halbe Körperbreite von Ian
McKellen ist.
Da schätze ich mal 30cm als Radius.
Dann brauchen wir noch m!
Genau – m, naja das ist so ei typischer
amerikanischer Laster mit etwas 15 Tonnen an Masse.
Und wenn wir das alles einsetzen und ausrechnen,
dann kommt raus, dass in dieser Situation
ein Strom von 2.500 Ampere durch Magneto fließen
würde.
Das ist ziemlich viel.
Wenn wir uns zum Beispiel so ein Smartphone
hernehmen und das mal so grob überschlagen,
dann fließt das ein Strom von 0,5 bis 0,6
Ampere durch.
Das ist ja gar nix.
Wir haben Euch nochmal einen Toaster mitgebracht.
Henry wenn wir hier so einen knusprigen Toast
machen wollen – wie viel Strom fließt hier durch?
Welche Stromstärke?
Das sind so 5 bis 6 Ampere ungefähr.
5, 6 Ampere. Da sind wir auch noch meilenweit von Magneto entfernt und der hier ist schon mega knusprig.
Das heißt also, wenn durch Magneto eine Stromstärke
von 2.500 Ampere fließt, dann ist Magneto auch knusprig.
Aber wie würde das jetzt eigentlich aussehen,
wenn tatsächlich Strom durch Magneto fließt?
Dafür hat Henry hier schon was aufgebaut
- Henry wir lassen jetzt ordentlich Strom fließen.
Das machen wir durch diese Spreewaldgurke!
Henry, ich geb die Dir mal und Du spannst
die hier ein und darf ich bitte den Schalter drücken?
Selbstverständlich.
Damit das auch eine richtige Magneto-Gurke
wird, muss natürlich der Magnetokopf noch drauf.
Den stecken wir hier drauf.
Und was wir jetzt gleich erwarten können
ist, das diese Gurke anfängt zu leuchten.
Irre.
Also Henry, Du sagst 3, 2, 1… 3, 2, 1…
Irre!
Boahh!
Wenn Ihr das riechen könntet – so riecht
Physik wenn man es richtig macht.
Stinkt ohne Ende!
Ganz schön mies..
Henry, fassen wir zusammen: Magneto könnte
mit ausreichend starken Magnetfeldern aus
seinem Plastikgefängnis ausbrechen aber irgendwie
doch nicht…
… weil er vorher weggebruzzelt wird und
qualmt.
Wie hat Euch das gefallen heute? Fandet Ihr das cool?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare!
Habt Ihr vielleicht eigene Superhelden, die
wir mal für Euch durchspielen sollen?
Dann lasst auch das bitte da!
Und ansonsten sehen wir uns nächste Woche
wieder. Bis dahin!